I like to start with your view I suppose
on the current turmoil and put it this
way you detail in your book the class of
83 if I could call it that the labor
intake of 1983 which contained two
future Prime Minister's Mr Blair and
yourself might it contain a third in
that that was when Jeremy Corbyn was
elected as well do you see the prospect
of him becoming Prime Minister the next
Labour Prime Minister after you that
prospect becoming more realistic well I
I don't think you ever sort of assumed
that something's going to happen you've
really got to work for it over the next
few years that there may not be an
election till 2022 but Jeremy Corbyn is
a phenomenon I mean he has managed to
change the nature of political debate in
this country he ran an excellent
campaign at the election interesting and
off the issues that he's talking about
you know I would agree with what he says
about universal credit and we've got to
get rid of that because it's not going
to work in the way it's a fashion with
three billion cuts and what he says
about tuition fees I've always favored a
graduate tax what he's saying about the
health service 20 billion money needed
by 2022 the health services at breaking
point in certain places on inequality so
Geoffrey Jeremy Corbyn is speaking to an
agenda where people are angry about
what's happening but you know the
biggest issue is is people's concerns
about taming globalization and it is
true of America as it is of Europe as it
is of Britain and I think that this is
the dominant issue of this time how we
can deal with the insecurities and the
inequalities that have arisen from this
tumultuous period of change that I was
living through and I'm writing about
from the 1980s onwards when we have the
globalization of the economy the
destruction of much of manufacturing the
movement of parity to Asia and the
inequalities and insecurities that
arisen from us and Jeremy Corbyn is a
reflection of people's worries about
these things
but just on the manoosh I I suppose
political machinations at the moment do
you say the amount of being election to
2022 there might be one an awful lot
sooner looking at the government do you
see it falling apart well I think I
don't see it I think it is falling apart
and I think you don't know I mean I
don't know
in the cabinet from one minute to the
next and there's been so many changes
but you see the the Conservative Party
is riven by it splits over Europe and
she can't solve that even a cabinet
reshuffle has got to reflect some
balance of power between the anti
Europeans and the pro Europeans and
until we can resolve this at this at
this issue of Europe properly and until
we have a sense of direction for this
country I feel that Britain is losing
its confidence and I feel that she's got
to sure that there is purpose and
direction to this that this country and
that's not just about standards in
public life which has been the issue of
last week it's about dealing with tax
havens it's about dealing with the
health service and I feel that we're in
a appeared which is quite unprecedented
where the government does not have
direction now a Labour Party to win an
election has got to do three things
you've got to have your principles there
and to return to first principles in
opposition is the normal thing that all
parties do but then you've gotta have a
plan and a program and then you've got
to popularize it and of course Jeremy
and his team and I've got some time now
if there's no election immediately to
develop the plan and and get a popular
program underway we spent ages between
1983 and 1997 under Neil Kinnock and
John Smith and then Tony Blair to get
that winnable program and he's got to do
this in a very short period of time
now you mentioned trees mate we did you
have some sympathy for perhaps one
aspect of her personality which was
exposed during the the 2017 election in
that you write in your book where that
you weren't a a touchy-feely politician
you say
for me being conspicuously demonstrative
is uncomfortable I could easily have
been written by Theresa may well
possibly I mean I'm the son of the
Church of Scotland ministers she was the
daughter of Anglican clergyman I was
brought up to believe that you and you
get on with the job you don't show your
feelings in public you're actually
reticent and and undemonstrative and it
was very difficult for me because I went
through appeared where I was exposed in
public to huge attention when my
daughter died you may remember and my
son was born in that cystic fibrosis
and then at the same time I was trying
to protect my sons from from the media
glare I do
want them to grow up thinking that they
had some somehow worth terribly special
in the sense of being being in the
public eye and so I took a very
different view from other politicians to
keeping my sons in private and when I
left Downing Street people wrote me
letters and said because the son my sons
walked out with me they didn't actually
know that I had children and they didn't
know that there was such warmth as they
saw of a family so it may have been a
mistake but for me it's what you do and
to be judged on what you achieve rather
than what you say or what style you have
or whether you're Sherman or whether
you're slake and I'm not that kind of
politician and perhaps in the social
media age and also the television age
it's a more difficult thing thing thing
to do but I would prefer to be judged by
what I did and what I achieved rather
than how I sounded let me turn to
another issue perhaps one of your
cowering or most remembered achievements
which is of course the independence of
the of the Bank of England which were
now it's very very soon after assuming
power when you week Tony Blair's
autobiography yes he says it's his idea
quite explicitly he says on page 113 at
my journey I formed the desire to give
monetary policy over to the Bank of
England Gordon had come to the same
conclusion I mean there's other passages
as well Wei said in truth as with the
Bank of England independence the broad
framework on the economy nevermind
anything else was set by me so it was
Blair not black well I don't really want
to get into that but the fact of the
matter is that the plan for the Bank of
England independence was actually drawn
up by Ed Balls and he did all this work
on it in 1994 after putting it forward
to me as a as a proposal even and the
days before the general election of 1997
we had not decided that we'd go ahead
immediately it was not in the Labor
Party's manifesto and it was only on the
Monday before the election that I
actually decided we will go ahead with
us and we'll do it immediately and so it
happened the next Tuesday and it
happened suddenly and it didn't go
through the cabinet and it was I had to
form the cabinet members to get to get
it to get it through so you know Tony
supported the independence of the Bank
of England I actually
was determined to do immediately we got
into government and I think we've got to
give in balsam credit for joining up the
play okay but I mean but Tony actually
says you know quite explicitly as I say
that he that he came up with it and he
says I allowed Gordon to make the
statement and indeed gave him every
paean of praise I put my glasses on
during the rest because it's important
it and status in becoming the major
economic figure of the government I did
this because I thought he deserved it
because it was good for the whole thing
not to like a one-man show ie Tony
Blair's and thirdly not doing so would
have created considerable tension but it
had an unfortunate and long-lasting
consequence well you know it was Ed
Balls and either drew up the plan I mean
we actually worked on it for years not
not for not for weeks I think the plan
was actually the one that was eventually
implemented by the Treasury so I think
he can go back into the records and
that's what that's what would be shown
but but Tony was very supportive of the
indepence of the Bank of England as was
I and to be honest it's all history now
but what isn't history is even it seems
were on the subject what isn't history
is the tension between you and mr. Blair
I mean do you ever regret just overall
some of the rage that you had about his
reneging on the deal I don't think it
was rage I'll be honest I think it was
disappointment
you see the thing about politics is that
you've got to take a broader view of
this there's only a particular shelf
life that you do have in politics you
know you've got a trillion mature I know
media interviewers and celebrities like
yourself will last a long time but for a
politician people get fed up I mean they
see someone who's under interrogation
almost 24 hours a day the intrusive
media you know everything about this
politician within a few weeks of them
take it taking offers you get fed up
with them you get bored their
characteristics start to annoy you so I
don't think politicians in the future
are going to last more than an American
president you know American presidents
eight years but by six people are
getting used to the next one and you
really written off after six and I would
have thought six years is about the most
my problem was I've been chancellor for
10 10 years and therefore I had been at
the top of politics with Tony and other
people in the cab
for that period of time people knew me
and I think it was very difficult then
for people to see whatever you did
whatever happened it's very difficult
for people to see that you know when I
took over from Tony it was a complete
change from what it when it happened
before and I wanted to emphasize
continuity as well so I think Tony and I
have got to get used to the idea that
there's a limit to the number of years
you're going to have at the top and in
politics and I think the Conservative
Party are seeing that more that it may
be less of a limit now in the second
decade of the 21st century but you you
can't assume that you're going to have a
long shelf life at the top of politics
and I didn't and and perhaps you know if
we if we changed over a bit earlier
things might have been different yes
Gordon Brown it's been fascinating
talking to you thank you very much
indeed
thank you to reshape